HUNTER B-15
Loki, not a threat.
LOKI
I beg your pardon?
♪♪
TOM HIDDLESTON
What I love about playing Loki,
he plays all the
keys on the piano.
LOKI
Enough.
MOBIUS
See, I can play the heavy keys too.
KATE HERRON
Something I always try and bring to
everything I do is
digging into the emotion
LOKI
I'm a God.
SYLVIE
You're a clown.
KATE HERRON
Letting the characters be ugly in a way,
for me it feels a bit more real.
MOBIUS
Glorious purpose!
AUTUMN DURALD ARKAPAW
The world the production designers created
is very unique for Loki,
it has a lot of texture.
CHRISTINE WADA
Thank God that Loki and the MCU
has a sense of
humor for inspiration.
KEVIN R. WRIGHT
It was fun, it was weird,
we were able to create
all these bandit versions of Loki.
TOM HIDDLESTON
I feel like I'm having an identity crisis.
We have this amazing story
that's actually about
coming to terms with who you are.
I feel very grateful that I'm part of
a project that I think has probably
changed the direction of the MCU,
and I really want the fans to feel excited
and inspired about
where we go next.